[موسيقى]
يتسارعوا تصعيد في شمال سوريا السلطات
التركيه اتهمت وحدات حمايه الشعب الكرديه
باستهداف المدنيين بالقذائف في منطقه
قرقميش قرب معبر الحدودي باقليم غازي
عنتاب شمال الاراضي السوريه وقد بينت صور
مصارعه رجال الاطفاء الى اخماد نيران قيل
انها استهدفت شاحنه كما بينت صور اخرى
اثار دمار لحق بمدرسه ثانويه في المنطقه
نفسها هذه القذائف خلفت عددا من القتل
والمصابين كما جاء في مؤتمر صحفي لوزير
الداخليه التركي
كان هجوما بقضاء في الهاون من الجهه
الاخرى للحدود
حسب الخلاصه الاولى ثلاث قذائف استهدفت
مناطق سكنيه
هجمات جويه ضد قواعد للمسلحين الاكراد في
شمال سوريا وشمال العراق دمرت خلالها عددا
من الاهداف ردا على هجوم بقنبله في
اسطنبول قبل اسبوع اودي بحياه سته اشخاص
هجوم القت فيه انقره بالمسؤوليه على حزب
العمال الكردستاني المحظور الرئيس التركي
رجب طيب اردوغان تحدث عن احتمال اطلاق
عمليه بريه في سوريا غدا سلسله من الغارات
الجويه على مواقع الاكراد في سوريا
والعراق وهجمات صاروخيه على الاراضي
التركيه من سوريا